many voters say the economy and high gas
prices are top issues in this election
but for Karen enzolone attempts to
overturn the 2020 presidential election
means for her this midterm election is
about whether or not democracy survives
in America democracy is now definitely
on the ballot nothing else really
matters the economy won't matter the
price of gas won't matter if we don't
have our representative legal government
and Power
nothing else will matter
democracy except democracy yes and you
think it's under threat absolutely many
voters told us defending democracy was
top of their list of issues they're
voting for on Tuesday but why now
it all stems from January 6
2021. that's when supporters of Donald
Trump stormed the U.S Capitol to try to
prevent Congress from certifying the
election results
[Applause]
since then Trump has repeatedly said
falsely that it was a rigged election
but those false claims of a stolen
election have spread far and wide to
Republican candidates running in these
midterm elections and voters here in
Pennsylvania don't need to look too far
to see it for themselves meet Doug
mastriano he was among the Trump
supporters who stormed the capitol
grounds on January 6th while he didn't
go inside the capital itself and hasn't
been charged with a crime he has become
a central figure in supporting Trump's
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
now he's on the ballot Tuesday running
for governor in Pennsylvania
political scientists say candidates like
him are the reason why many voters say
democracy is top of mind they're going
to the polls to fight for our system of
government they're fighting going to
elect candidates who respect the
Integrity of elections who believe that
when the people speak at elections that
those votes should be honored those
votes should be followed they should not
be thrown out by elected officials or or
candidates who are upset the outcome and
so I think that's what's on a lot of
Voters Minds when they say that
Democrats hoping that will be all it
takes to win enough races to keep
control of Congress Gabriel ozando Al
Jazeera Pittsburgh